[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the president announced
this afternoon that the republican party
has canceled its traditional nominating
convention in florida next month
the reason coronavirus this afternoon my
political team came to me and laid out
our plans for the convention in
jacksonville florida
it's a place i love i love that state
but i looked at my team and i said
the timing for this event is not right
it's just not right with what's happened
recently the flare-up in florida
to have a big convention it's not the
right time
well that news will certainly
inconvenience some people it's without
precedent in recent history but in the
end
it's hard to believe that canceling a
political convention will affect the
outcome
ultimately of this year's presidential
election yet it is very likely that the
chronovirus lockdowns themselves
will affect the outcome and here's why
the most basic question political
polling never changes
is your country on the right track or
the wrong track
in a re-election campaign especially
that is always the central
question every political consultant in
america knows that
there is no poll the biden campaign pays
closer attention to
than the daily right track wrong track
numbers especially now
presidential election in fact believe it
or not is almost here
in some places early voting begins in
just over a month
the results of that voting will define
the country's future
if democrats take both the senate and
the white house and they could
you will not recognize america a year
from now
think about how much things have changed
just over the past six months
now imagine what would have happened if
there had been no meaningful opposition
to the mob if alexandria ocasio-cortez
had been able to impose her plans
without any restraint
that's exactly what they intend to do if
they win
they're not hiding it if mitch mcconnell
tries to do
what he did to president obama then we
should get rid of the filibuster
raise your hand if governor if your
government plan would provide coverage
for undocumented immigrants
that is why we will implement
legislation
based on the principles of the green new
deal
[Applause]
are you proposing taking away their guns
and how would this work
i am if it's a weapon that was designed
to kill people
on a battlefield hell yes we're going to
take your ar-15 your ak-47
it's funny because when people ask me
what does a world
where we defund the police where you
know defunding police looks like
i tell them it looks like a suburb well
say what you will about the people you
just saw they are not
moderates this is not the democratic
party you remember
dopey liberals with flaccid ideas that
you probably had contempt for
but in the end could live with no these
are radicals
they despise the country they seek to
govern they plan to remake it completely
these people want power with an
intensity that you
as a normal well-adjusted person cannot
even begin to understand
they will do anything for control so the
question is what are they doing
to win well they're working the right
track wrong track numbers
democrats understand that the unhappier
americans become the more likely they
are
to win unhappy people want
change it is not complicated so
every ominous headline about the state
of the country makes it
more likely that donald trump will lose
his job the more that people suffer
the greater joe biden's advantage
democrats have a strong
incentive therefore to inflict as much
pain as they can
and that's what they're doing on march
1st new york state confirmed its first
case of the chronovirus
at the time you may not remember the
media were still attacking the
president for taking the wuhan
chronovirus too seriously
they said his travel ban on china was
hysterical and xenophobic
two days later citing the pandemic ohio
governor mike dewine banned spectators
from a sporting event
and the washington post scoffed at him
the paper called dewine's restrictions
quote
radical on that day march 3rd more than
40 percent of americans thought the
country was headed in the right
direction
and for the biden campaign that number
was way too high
then within a week higher education
began to shut down and life really
started to change for many people
hundreds of thousands of idle college
age kids returned home
stores began to empty hand sanitizers
cleaning supplies
disappeared on march 12th the national
hockey league cancelled its season major
league baseball followed suit they ended
spring training
suddenly there were no sports movie
theaters closed so did bowling alleys
and yet still 40 of americans continued
to believe that their country
was headed in the right direction and
that was bad news for the joe biden
campaign
so then came the shutdowns the cdc
recommended cancelling
all public events with more than 50
people present public schools closed
so did bars restaurants gyms and
churches
critically millions lost their jobs when
businesses were shuttered the
unemployment rate rose to the highest
level in nearly a century
now at the time they told us that mass
quarantines were essential they were a
public health measure
we were saving lives with our suffering
most people wanted to believe that
because most americans are decent people
but as summer approached it became clear
that the people telling us that
were lying science had nothing to do
with this
studies from around around the world
showed that being outside was far
safer than staying at home that was
conclusive and yet governors continued
to maintain mandatory shelter in place
orders
in michigan which is not coincidentally
as a swing state
democrats banned citizens from visiting
their own weekend homes
or using outboard motors in new jersey
people were arrested for going to the
beach
after a while the authorities issuing
these orders stopped trying to pretend
that they were backed up with reason or
data
anthony fauci who for a long time seemed
like a serious man of science
announced that it was very dangerous to
shake hands with the people you love
but it was fine to have sex with
strangers you meet online
like anthony fauci himself the
chronovirus lockdowns
were revealed to be capricious and
transparently political
above all though and this was the point
they made americans
miserable prescriptions for
anti-depressants rose 21
in a single month by the end of april
the right track wrong track number
inverted
just 22 percent of those polled believe
the country was on the right track
and yet for the people pushing joe biden
for president that number was still too
high
so we had riots as the entire country
watched in real time mobs
looted and burned a police station in
minneapolis we saw americans
dragged from their stores and beaten
unconscious on camera some were killed
most people watching were horrified by
this of course
but professional democrats were thrilled
by it they slashed police budgets to
ensure it would continue
and it did crime rates soared the
crackdown on normal people
accelerated your kids weren't allowed to
have graduation ceremonies or get
married
but hundreds of thousands of confirmed
joe biden voters were allowed to flood
the streets and break things
and then mid-summer came with the
election just months away america's
suffering had to be intensified it was a
political imperative
so schools across the country announced
they would stay closed in the fall
no one bothered to explain the science
behind this because
there wasn't any school children remain
nearly immune to the fatal effects of
the coronavirus
to this day there is not a single
recorded case in the entire world
of a student passing covet 19 to a
teacher not one case
but schools shut down anyway desperate
parents wondered what they were going to
do with their kids in september
good luck they were told figure
something out residents of washington dc
were told they would be required by law
to wear masks everywhere they went for
the foreseeable future
and yet the people who made that law
exempted themselves from it
they already know they're voting for joe
biden everyone else in the country
became dramatically
unhappier nearly three-quarters of
americans now say their country has
become a much worse place than
it was doctors have prescribed so much
zoloft the antidepressant that is now on
the federal drug shortage list
in fact it is likely that americans have
never in the history of this country
been as unhappy as they are right now
it's a tragedy but for democrats it's a
win
according to polls republicans may now
lose once safe senate seats in iowa and
montana
just to name two so say what you all
about the destruction of america
but as a political matter it's been a
stroke of genius